oh i gotta ask what is the most messed
up one
that you would say that you'd be like
it's hard actually actually
that's sorry because obviously some of
them do try to be really [ __ ] up and
it's
like kind of comes off as like cringey
like oh my god you're actually you're
[ __ ] that girl's intestines like come
on like you're just trying too hard yeah
um but some of them are just like oh
i didn't know you could do that because
because there's an entire genre for that
right
yeah it's just that's something that i
even i don't want to touch like i don't
know i don't
i don't like it like i've been trying to
dive into that side of things just
because
no one else wants to yeah so i'm just
like how bad it's a good reason for good
good reason how bad could it be i'm like
the the little that i've seen i'm just
like
i understand now yes this is bad no this
is something where
like if if i see something like error
guru i have to like completely separate
myself
from like that work and just view it as
like a piece of like
i am soft as a pillow
i'm open to a lot of like different
sexual things like you know different
fetishes that you knew
yeah aragora though if you're into that
[ __ ] don't come here
don't come near me i don't even think
that like incognito mode can save you oh
no
no no no no there was a okay so i was
also trying to get into eroguto probably
trying to take a make a video on it
so i in japan when i was at a dodgy
store
they had like these magazines that are
actually i didn't know until later we're
kite famous
for guru which is called irogurus yeah
yeah and uh
do you know them yeah yeah and um i read
one
and of course it's in japanese so i
didn't fully understand everything but i
will say uh
the dead baby stuff is not my favorite
what baby stuff isn't i don't want it i
don't think we need to go
any further than that yeah
[ __ ] probably best to wait for either me
or sydney to make a video if we
eventually get there but
um no but i totally get what you mean
like some some like doujins that are
just like trying to be
way too edgy are just like come on yeah
we know you're trying but then there are
the
actually [ __ ] up stuff like
metamorphosis for example right like
i reckon like if there was one i'd still
say that's my favorite doujin even
though it completely [ __ ] me up the
first time i read it
your favorite yeah it's my favorite
because it's my favorite because like
because i don't know like i i like a lot
of stories that are
quite depressing where like you you
watch a character go from sad wank or
what
no no no because that's the thing it was
it was like an
existential one why am i here
metamorphosis was the first time where i
was like i was prepared to go in for a
wank but then i
had to let go and be like okay hold on
zipper going up yeah
zipper going up because i i'm soft right
now
but but for a good reason right because
it's like that because that story is
like
i mean i'm sure sydney can vouch for
this or whoever has red metal morphosis
can vouch for this but it's like
it go it's a dojin but there it goes
beyond the dojo
you know yeah like how do you find it
i definitely when i first because when i
first heard of it i was actually
i think from aki's video when she made a
video just saying like oh it's really
messed up and i'm like
okay i think i've been around the block
but no i definitely wasn't expecting
like
majority because i also am a big fan of
depressing things
i'm a big fan of depression i love the
work it does and um
so when i yeah no uh so when all that
started happening
when you know she graduated and all that
yeah you know
we won't go into detail yeah that's nice
i was definitely sat
once i finished i just sat looking at
like the ceiling on the bed just like
where am i what did i do why did i
what did i do to deserve being here
right now what did i do wrong in my life
what i think about metamorphosis it's
likely a yasmi pinpoint of hentai
it is you know what i mean straight up
is and i think that's why i love it
jesus christ no because like because uh
because i did i
i interviewed shindo well the creator of
metamorphosis and uh i asked him about i
obviously had to ask him about that
right and
he said it in a really cool way which is
like i wrote that story
not to give this entire shock value of
like
i wrote a messed up dozen but because
but because he was raised in america
he's like i've seen so many people whose
lives
end up like this and i wanted to show it
not to like
fetishize it so much but more so to show
off like
this can happen to people yeah yeah and
if you find this like
hot or attractive then there's kind of
something wrong with you i'm i'm not
showing it as a type of fetish i'm
showing it as like
he's basically he's like i'm throwing
out a message right
it's about it's about sending a message
hentai is
art that's what i'm trying to say he he
gave the hentai
it's like i wrote that because i wanted
to show it off in an artistic way and
for the first time i was like
you know what that didn't sound
pretentious wow
you're one of the first people who are
like okay i totally get it because
because i was the same thing when i read
it i was like is this just edgy
or am i thinking about this like way too
artistically but then when you finish
reading you're like
okay no it is actually quite artistic
yeah yeah definitely
you should read it yeah which is which
is like how long is it
uh it's like a hundred and something
yeah second didn't like
it's one volume it's like yeah